so as we round out our discussion on the
concepts surrounding black panther what
I want to do here is run over the metals
of vibranium and adamantium and what I'm
hoping is that at the end of all this
you'll have a stronger understanding of
these two metals as well as why each is
considered wildly powerful in their own
right
the so within Marvel Comics vibranium
exists in two forms wakandan vibranium
and Antarctic vibranium while the wakana
variety is the most well known due to
its involvement in the design of Captain
America shield its history with black
and occult and his involvement in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe both wakandan
Amon Arctic vibranium have their own
unique properties that complement the
various strengths and weaknesses
originally introduced in daredevil
volume 1 issue no 13 entitled the secret
of kaizar origin and Arctic vibranium
was actually introduced first and
resided in the Savage Land to side track
here in my video on the beyonders and
their interactions with the Marvel
Universe prior to the start of Secret
Wars 2016 they had experimented with
human evolution but could only do so by
working through races native to our
universe due to their inability to leave
their own reality as a result the
beyonders began working with a race
called the new ally for the purpose of
creating an isolated area on earth away
from the human involvement which could
be used as a kind of Game Preserve
allowing for the monitoring of various
species from across the landscape as
they evolved over the years
the key to Antarctica the Savage Land
was created using technological devices
to create a temperate jungle climate
which was filled with various creatures
including dinosaurs insects and
primitive man now when savage land has
played an important role in the history
of Marvel comics I've seen characters
like Magneto discovering its location
and experimenting on the organisms with
him as well as various beings that using
the Savage Land as their base of
operations on the whole the larger
population of Earth is completely
unaware of its existence
that said what we're told in this
particular comic is that at some point
in the past
Lord Robert plunder a British nobleman
Explorer and scientist had discovered
the Savage Land while looking for
precious metals that were unavailable in
the rest of the world discovering a
chunk of metal before he was able to
split it open the metal began to
irradiated a way that disrupted the
metal all around it causing the various
items in the ring to break down on the
molecular level and dissolve spending
months studying the Antarctic form of
vibranium robber plunder came to realize
that the range of its radiation was
based on the mass of the vibranium
meaning the more of it existed in one
place the larger its radius of influence
now because his story focused on the
origin of kaizar who is a tarzan-like
ruler of the Savage Land what we learn
is that after discovering that the metal
was capable of laying waste to the
world's militaries if put in the wrong
hands due to its ability to dissolve
metals Robert plunder sealed the metal
away in a vault accessible only through
a small medallion fashioned from a
chipped off piece of the Arctic
vibranium splitting it in half and
providing a piece to each of his two
sons the hopes of Robert founder was
that they would both grow into heroes
who would either protect the vibranium
or use it in a heroic fashion turning
his power on villains who sought to
bring harm to the world now
transitioning to a common vibranium
unlike the Antarctic variety the origin
of this version is far less developed
referencing my video on the history of
Wakanda and the Black Panther tribe all
we really know is that at some point
around 10,000 years ago both of a Condon
and Antarctic versions of vibranium
landed on earth by way of a meteor crash
and their respective locations
discovered by bashing guy the leader of
a local tribe near the Egyptian border
because the metal discovered by the
shinga would have allowed him and his
tribe to rise to prominence amidst their
enemies who were still using stone and
wood for their weapons but she never
edition the Egyptian god vast to bestow
him with the powers of the Panther in
order to safeguard the wakandan
vibranium from those who would seek to
use it for evil but also ensure the
future nation of Wakanda
which serve as one of Bath's loyal
followers without fear of being
destroyed
now while Marvel has never offered an
explanation on why Antarctic vibranium
breaks down metal on the molecular level
while wakandan vibranium absorbs various
energies even if only by speculation we
can make a legitimate argument that
these two forms exists in a kind of yin
and yang because of the respective
properties if were Condon in an Arctic
vibranium were pitted against one
another
it would stand to reason that the anti
metal properties of the Antarctic
variant would be absorbed by the
wakandan variant notifying its effects
at the same time if the wakandan variant
struck the Antarctic variant it would
stand to reason that the Antarctic
variant would be unaffected
since both contain the same basic
metallic properties but having said that
while both forms of vibranium are
relatively well hidden throughout the
world whether by selling small portions
to keep the nation wealthy or through
thievery vibranium from both Wakanda and
the Antarctic have made their way into
the rest of the world and have been used
in a multitude of different ways through
the various crossovers and solo runs
Marvel has shown vibranium to be used by
heroes like Hawkeye in the form of
arrows capable of nullifying kinetic
energies allowing the arrows to
literally stop a villain at the
juggernaut by temporarily eliminating
his momentum while Heroes for Hire
leader misty Knight had a metal arm
composed of antarctica rhenium which
allowed her to nullify the properties of
all metals in existence including the
guru medal of Asgard which was used to
forge Thor's hammer conversely for
recent unexplained Colossus organic
metal form will automatically regress
and return him to his human form when
confronted with either wakandan or
antarctic vibranium now where both forms
of vibranium will go on to have their
own influences within the Marvel
Universe which you can find in my video
on Wakanda explained I want to take a
second to have a discussion about how
this particular metal actually resulted
in the formation of adamantium covered
in Captain America issues 302 and 303 as
well as Avengers issue number 66
following his efforts to help will count
escape off an attack by Red Skull Adolf
Hitler and Baron von Strucker during
World War two Steve Rogers was provided
a sample of vibranium by wakanda's ruler
as a reward and an indication of
gratitude taking this time to fashion a
new shield the sample was given to the
US government who in turn handed the
sample over to a man named IRA McClane
for the purpose of creating a new shield
for Captain America but also
investigating practical applications for
the US military where this would come to
fruition during the experiment by Myron
he had actually fallen asleep resulting
in the vibranium bonding with unknown
elements two of which were later
discovered to be iron and adamantium
looking to recreate the formula bar and
began to combine vibranium with a series
of different metals none of which seemed
to compete with the durable properties
of Captain America shield
however in an act of desperation Myron
began to produce a series of alloys
combining them together and suddenly
across the formula for pure adamantium
coveted Avengers vol 1 issues 201 and
202 while the exact composition of pure
adamantium has never been revealed
within Marvel what we're told is that
these various alloys are all kept in
isolation for one another to prevent
impurities from occurring because the
basics of chemistry stayed the chemical
reactions are a result of heat and
pressure using a specialized molecular
resonator the various components appear
adamantium are combined and heated to
1500 degrees whether allowed to mix and
then cool down resulting in an
astronomically hard substance which is
capable of cutting through all
substances with the exception of Captain
America shield now having said that
because each of these metals have their
own properties regarding the usefulness
and durability they're highly valuable
and extremely sought after but have also
fallen into less savory hands on a
multitude of occasions referencing my
videos on the history of the Weapon X
project because the secret behind
Captain America Super Soldier Serum died
with dr. Abraham Erskine much like
minors attempts to recreate a shield the
US government had attempted to recreate
the Super Soldier Serum operating under
the overarching concept of weapons plus
the weapon one through nine projects
focused on a combination of genome
modification and cybernetic implants to
enhance the abilities of normal humans
and animals however under the direction
of Department K within the Canadian
government adamantium was introduced as
a viable supplement to enhance the
skeletal structures of mutants and
humans while only characters like
Wolverine and Sabretooth were capable of
surviving the skeletal bonding process
due to their healing factors adamantium
is presented in other characters like
bullseye Lady Deathstrike x-23 and
Ultron with others like Hawkeye Reed
Richards Agent Zero and Moon Knight
using adamantium weapons or facilities
now where adamantium itself is largely
considered indestructible by
conventional means if we leave out the
concept of beings like Magneto or
Franklin Richards and gods like the
Celestials who can alter or manipulate
the molecular structure of matter as far
as I know the only thing capable of
damaging true adamantium is antarctic
vibranium due to its radiation
permeating all medals including
adamantium on the molecular level making
them unstable and causing the breakdown
with that in mind in Marvel Comics
like vibranium adamantium actually
exists in several forms where true
adamantium is present in the bodies of
Wolverine and Sabretooth most all other
anime atiim in existence is considered
to be secondary
while the elements making up this form
are also left ambiguous secondary
adamantium is not as durable as its true
form and can be damaged by beings of
extreme strength like world worker Hulk
Thor under the Warriors madness whereby
he loses his ability to think rationally
and flies into a state of rage Tarek's a
destroyer empowered by the lattice or
apocalypse at full strength with that
being said we're gonna bring this video
to an end and let me know what you guys
think about these metals in Marvel
Comics so you guys want me to just run
over all the other metals like guru
metal and carbonadium and dargah Knight
I think it is it was mentioned in
guardians of the galaxy once and I don't
think has ever been mentioned since let
me know what you guys think
then I will catch you all later peace